فلتامر الجيش بالتاهب فقد حان الوقت
لنتدخل هكذا قالها مع اول هجوم بحري
وكوريا وامريكا وحلفائها يردون عسكريا
واوكرانيا تبتعد عن بخموت وتقترب من
الدول الاوروبيه تحضر استيراد المنتجات
الاوكرانيه فيا لها من صفعه على الخد
الاوكراني وثائق الامريكان المسربات تواصل
اثاره الجدل وتخلق فوضى في الداخل
الامريكي والعراق يدخل خط الوساطه
الاوكرانيه فهل ياتي الحل على ايدي ابناء
الرافدين والمنطاد الصيني يعود من جديد
لكن هذه المره بفضيحه للولايات المتحده
والتسريبات تؤكد كرر وفر وشد وجذب في
المعارك السودانيه وكل يدلو بدلوه لمن
ستكون الغلبه بوتين يحمل هديه للش التركي
والاسلام يغزو مدينه امريكيه روسيا تدخل
مرحله حرب جديده اصوات المدافع لا تهدا
وازير الرصاص لا يتوقف هنا وهناك الجنود
يتساقطون كاوراق الخريف والخسائر فادحه
ولا تعلن الدفاع الروسيه عن تدمير اربع
مسيرات في جمهوريتي دونتسكو واحباط
محاولات استطلاع وتخريب وتعلن ايضا
استهداف ثلاثه مستودعات ذخيره اوكرانيه في
دونتسكا وتصفيه اكثر من
335 جنديا اوكرانيا لكن يبدو انك لا تبالي
بخسائرها في جميع المحاور حيث بدات القوات
الاوكرانيه بتكثيف عملياتها لتقترب باتجاه
زبروجه وذلك برغم تصدي المدفعيه الروسيه
لتحبط ايام محاولات هجوميه وذلك بحسب
وسائل اعلام روسيه مهلا فه الصراخ الجنود
يرتفع ليشدنا للحديث اكثر عن المعركه
القادمه للقوات الاوكرانيه والتي قد تكون
حاسمه لاحد الطرفين في اوكرانيا بريطانيا
تعطي حقنه من الاحباط للجيش الاوكراني
بقولها انه عند محاوله قوتك التقدم فهم
يخاطرون بانفسهم بالوقوع في مواقع الروس
المحصنه والتي تحتوي على حقول ملغومه
وخنادق مضاده للدبابات مضيفه ان الجيش
الاوكراني في حاجه ماسه الى دعم جوي
بالطيران والذي بدونه تكون فرصه التحول
لاي عمليه من هذا القبيل الى هزيمه ساحقه
كبيره وذلك بحسب صحيفه
وما دام الحل موجودا في السلاح الجوي اذا
لماذا لا تعطون الاوكران بعضا من طائراتكم
احفاد اليزابيث الضربات تتوالى على
الاوكرانيين من اوروبا وهذه المره ق حظر
استيراد الحبوب الاوكرانيه والمنتجات
الزراعيه الاخرى لتصبح ثالث دوله تعلن عن
ذات القرار في فتره وجيزه وذلك بسبب مشاكل
في اسعارها وفق تصريحات الاوروبيين وعلى
ضوء المعارك اعلن مسؤول رفيع بالرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان 130 اسيرا اوكرانيا اطلق
سراحهم واعيد الى ديارهم في تبادل كبير
للاسرى بمناسبه عيد الفصحى والذي يحتفل به
المسيحيون وهذه هي ثاني عمليه تبادل كبيره
بالاسرى في غضون اسبوع ومن تبادل الاسرى
جاءت الفرصه للحديث عن وساطه بايقاف الحرب
لينتهز العراق الفرصه وبعد ان استقبلت
الحكومه العراقيه وزير الخارجيه الروسي ها
هي اليوم تستقبل وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
في بغداد في زياره هي الاولى من نوعها منذ
انطلاق العمليه العسكريه الروسيه اوكرانيا
وذلك حتى تبدا المفاوضات بين الطرفين لوقت
اطلاق النار وفق فرانس فهل يفعلها بلاد
الرافدين كما فعلها قبل مده قصيره عندما
استضاف اللقاءات الاوليه بين السعوديه
وايران قبل الصلح التاريخي من المصالحه
العراقيه الى البرطه الامريكيه والتي لا
تنتهي حيث تستمر قضيه الوثائق السريه
المسربه التي اثرت جدا خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه في الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها والجديد هذه المره هو اعاده فتح
ملف منطاد التجسس الصيني وما اخفته اداره
بايدن حيث كشفت الوثائق السريه المسربه ان
البنتاجون رصد اربعه تجسس صينيه صنع حلق
احدها فوق حامله طائرات امريكيه ولم يتم
الابلاغ عنه فلماذا تخفي اداره العجوز
الامريكي تلك المعلومات برايكم ولا زلنا
في الولايات المتحده عبر مستشار البنتاجون
السابق العقيد المتقاعد عن اعتقاده بان
السلطات الامريكيه خططت لتطوير انظمه
الاسلحه بشكل خاطئ ما ظهر واضحا اثناء
الازمه الاوكرانيه مشددا على ضروره بناء
علاقات طبيعيه مع موسكو وفقا
الحرب السودانيه لا تنطفئ اعمده الدخان في
كل مكان والانفجارات تدوي في مختلف
الارجاء السودانيه وحال الشعب السوداني
فهلا اوقفتم الحرب ايها السودانيون لكن
المتحاربين في السودان لا يتوقفون القوات
الدعم السريع تعلن سيطرتها على القصر
الجمهوري والجيش السوداني يعلن ان قواته
دخلت برج القوات البريه في القياده العامه
السودانيون يفطرون ويمسكون على قلوبهم قبل
ان يلمسوا حبه التمر اصوات المدافع
والرصاص
باصوات الاذان الاشتباكات تشتد في الخرطوم
والاهالي ينزحون بعيدا لتنهي المواجهات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
يومها الثاني مسفره عن سقوط سته وخمسين
قتيلا بين المدنيين واكثر من 60 مئه جريح
والعداد لا يتوقف وكل الطرف يعلن سيطرته
على مقر ودوائر الطرف الاخر والعالم يطالب
بتهدئه النفوس ايها السودانيون فلا تعقلتم
قليلا وغلبتم جانب العقل وبين الكر والفر
في هذه المعارف اهمها هي معركه السماء حتى
وان كان الهدف على الارض في السودان القوه
هناك في القواعد الجويه قوات الدعم السريع
لا تمتلك قوه جويه وتعلم ان من يمتلك
الاجواء يحسم المعركه ليبدا الجيش
باستغلال نقطه قوته باستخدام ثلاث طائرات
في القتال حتى الان وحرب ط تدور للاستيلاء
على قاعده مروي لاحتوائها اكبر عدد من
الطائرات واحدثها فمن يسيطر عليها في
نهايه الامر وفي خضم تلك المعارك الطاحنه
اتفق الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
على اقتراح اممي بفتح مسارات مؤقته امنه
للحالات الانسانيه اعتبارا من الرابعه
عصرا ولساعات محدوده
يتحرش عسكريا اطلاق الصواريخ واجراء
المناورات خطوات متبادله في الجزيره
الكوريه بين شماليا وجنوبها لكن هذه المره
لحظات بسيطه هي منفصلت عن مواجهه خطيره
بين الكوريتين في البحر ضمن المياه
الدوليه المتنازع عليها وبعد ان اطلقت
زوارق من كوريا الجنوبيه على اخرى من
الشماليه طلقات تحذيريه قالت هيئه الاركان
المشتركه لكوريا الجنوبيه ان القاربه عبر
خط الحد الشمالي بالقرب من جزيره بكري
يونج في كوريا الجنوبيه مضيفه ان القارب
فائق السرعه التابعه للبحريه بعث برسائل
تحذير واطلق عيارات تحذيريه وصد على الفور
زورق الدوري دوريه الشماليه يؤكد الجيش
الجنوبي استعداده لمواجهه مختلف
الاستفزازات للحفاظ على موقع قتالي حاسم
مع مراقبه تحركات العدو عن كثب وللعلم
كوريا الشماليه وزعيمها لا يعترفون رسميا
للحدود بين البلدين سواء البريه او
البحريه ويعتبرون انفسهم في حاله حرب
مستمره مواصلين تهديد الجاره الجنوبيه
الاحداث والتطورات
اكتمال عمليه تبادل الاسرى بين الطرفي
النزاع في اليمن والافراج عن اكثر من 880
اسيرا ومعتقلا من الجانبين بينهم
السعوديون والسودانيون بل سيكتب بذلك
نهايه حرب دامت لاكثر من ثماني سنوات
نتمنى ذلك اعتبارا من صباح الاحد السادس
عشر من ابريل في العام الحالي اصبحت
المانيا بدون اي محطه طاقه نوويه عامه بعد
ان اغلقت اخر محطه ناقبه 60 عاما من عملها
اعلنت السلطات التركيه ان سفينه شحن روسيه
تنقل اكثر من 180 طنا من المساعدات
الانسانيه الى تركيا لضحايا الزلازل
المدمره التي وقعت في فبراير الماضي في
سابقه تاريخيه تصبح اول مدينه امريكيه
تسمح برفع الاذان في جميع اوقات الصلاه
السودان ياخذ الرايه من اوكرانيا ليعلن
المتحاربون فيه عن معاركهم الضاريه فهل
تتعظ الخرطوم مما تجنيه الحروب
[موسيقى]